did you bury the lead there how did you
all put this together her dancing
singing doing all this pregnant
listen she's an incredible individual
that's all I can say she's a one of one
but still
she's pregnant that is a lot that is I
mean that changes everything didn't it
when you went in what was the whole
process when you found out
I mean for us it was just focusing on
the performance so what's going on in
her life we were dialed in on the
performance it was just about that
choreography picking those songs getting
that creative that production that's all
we were focused on okay let's talk about
the insane floating stages how you came
up with that how you pulled that off the
look The the danger of that in an open
stadium and you know and apparently
she's scared of heights but um she got
it together for this um I have to give
the credit uh Willow Perrin her creative
director came up with that idea along
with her choreographer Paris and they
just they were just it was just
unbelievable you know we were on a grass
field there were weight concerns and we
were like you can only do this much on
the field and they were like well we'll
just put it all in the air
and that's the G the heat reports and
where you can and can't stand exactly
exactly this is a grass field and it's
um you know it's like a sponge
and so you if you had put last year's
halftime show on that field it wouldn't
have worked so how did you acclimate her
to the hike
we've been we've been working since
November she was flying in December back
in La so we've been just getting her
ready ready ready and then she got here
last week and practically every night
she's been flying what was that like the
first time you put her up on I mean I
was impressed because I I went up 10
feet and had them bring me back down
because I was terrified but she was 60.
that was 60 feet she was 60 feet high
and she said she was actually more
comfortable all the way up at the top
she loved it at the top
how did you fix the setlist deal because
I heard you were changing the setlist or
at least that's what she said oh yeah
she had been I mean she was up to
version 39 right yeah yeah it was just I
mean she has a massive catalog not a lot
of time
and her and Adam Blackstone just
noodling noodling noodling and she just
she wasn't gonna be ready until it was
absolutely perfect what were the biggest
challenges for you producing something
like this in that Stadium
I think it's the first time we've ever
done something where the performer is
primarily in the air for at least 30 40
percent of it
um you know there's so much Intrigue
around her so keeping everything quiet
not easy the setlist you saw I saw today
we were betting there were odds on what
the first song was so I mean we had to
rehearse way out in the sticks in LA and
Santa Clarita to keep keep it all
secretive it was a lot of work it was a
lot of work and then how do you keep it
secret that she's pregnant I mean that's
hard too because it's none of my
business
I don't have nothing to do with nothing
she also did this alone
she stood alone how was that
choreography how did you do the
choreography and everything for her to
do it alone
I think it was just
her wanting to make the statement that
she could carry this thing and she did
and people would just want to see her
and so she had to give him a show and
she did choreography we haven't seen her
dance like that in a long time and I
thought it was just spectacular how do
you take a deep breath you pull off
another one of these and what goes
through your mind is that that thing
ends and she gets risen up into the
ground what goes through your mind
because you've pulled off a couple of
incredible Super Bowls I I just think
honestly as soon as it's done I was like
oh now let's get her back down just get
everybody get her back on the ground
that's all I want to do is get her back
on the ground but like the relief that
everything came off the way we wanted
you know it was a lot a lot of prep a
lot of nerves and um just really happy
to be a part of it so
who back in November that you're gonna
fly her so you had to start in November
it was always the plan to uh have her
fly like that it was never a it was
never a primarily on the ground uh show
was there ever a thought we saw Cali get
here we saw Jay-Z was here was there
ever a thought of adding him to the show
was always her you know there were a lot
of ideas kicking around but we landed on
just her she landed on just doing it
herself and uh she was right
100 right explain the dancers in the
outfits explain that listen you'd have
to get with her team about that you know
that was they designed those outfits it
was kind of an alien vibe that she said
she was going for and um it was
incredible it was incredible the
choreography I thought was spectacular
so I want to just make it clear that
grass starts dying as soon as you bring
it in is what I heard that so that was
the big thing that that's grass all week
yeah what has that been like the
pressure from the NFL
listen the NFL's been really supportive
but they've also let us know that every
day we would get those heat reports on
the damage that we were doing to the
field and we would have to adjust things
because um you know player set player
safety is key and uh we want to make
sure that um that everything is the way
it's supposed to be you're incredible
you are I mean seriously I can't it's
incredible
I walked in I saw the station I was like
what is that and then they started
floating and I was like what the hell is
happening no it's like but you got to
think about it it felt like a high
fashion
that's what she is what that first shot
was insane it looked like CGI
Hamish got that we were with this with
the steady cams we're looking at and
where we we we debated a long time about
what the opening shot was going to be
and then Hamish discovered that and
everybody was like that's it we're done
that's the opening shot
[Music]